brothers and sisters he's telling me i
used to struggle reading the quran daily
before you instructed instructed me to
download this app brothers and sisters
can you imagine someone struggling and
he has downloaded the quran app and
built a habit and now he's regularly
reading and he's gone out of his way to
message me to thank me i never knew that
this app would have such an impact on
people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for ios
and android and build your habit with
the quran right now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
today i wanted to catch up on a video
where a group of afghani um football
team girls team or something like that
along those lines uh were flown uh uh to
the united kingdom by kim kardashian and
a few other individuals uh basically
they're not sure they were saved by the
taliban um
the taliban has made some legislations
or rules that you cannot play sports or
something along those lines now i wanted
to touch upon this because very
important reminder for us to benefit
from um i want to play a little video
and let's quickly watch that we're going
to come back because i find a video a
little bit disturbing in some senses
let's watch it
[Applause]
the 30 teenage girls soccer players and
their families about 130 people in all
safely to britain from pakistan it's a
privilege to be part of this life-saving
mission to save the afghan female youth
national team all girls have the right
to be whatever they want to be they are
courageous and it's tragic they had to
flee their country because they wish to
play a sport they love the video that
you guys saw there the football team is
there they're happy and i think kim
kardashian is there if i'm not mistaken
and they're just rejoicing the gash is
there etc and i'm trying to understand
the hype now we want to firstly be
appreciative because i don't know if
somebody helps anybody we should be
appreciative so we appreciate the fact
that kim kardashian thinks of thought
that their lives might be in danger
whatever it may be we don't know if
that's true or not and she has helped
him that's calm but if the hype and gas
being gassed or being joy being happy is
because of who she is there's a big
question mark on this because what does
kim kardashian have to offer she is a
person blessed be real
she there's there was a profession
what's she known for nothing you know
there was a
excuse my language kids if you're
watching this please don't watch there
was a
sex movie that came out with her and her
ex-boyfriend she's somebody who casually
sleeps around who is known for nothing
but her beauty and the only thing that
she has to offer
so what is there to rejoice about why is
it that we have an inferiority complex
that we are so gassed and happy
about what what is she offered now like
i said before again if the hype is
because she's kim kardashian etc
the question that we need to ask
ourselves is
why why are we so hyped about it and one
thing i want to say is most of the times
we see certain things that happen and we
look at individuals like why do we have
this attitude where if a really famous
person that has nothing to offer my life
at all zero when i see them i get hyped
like oh my gosh why what do you have to
offer nothing you live a disgusting life
a sinful life
a very filthy life let's be very honest
here a very feel-free life etc now
people can change i'm not saying they
won't change but i'm talking about the
current situation you know there is
nothing that you have to offer in moral
value to anybody so when i saw this
football team come in etc rejoicing i
wouldn't give an analogy forget the
taliban i don't care about the taliban
what they do what they don't do my point
is not that okay if you are in a country
and in that country for example um it
has certain regulations for example yeah
every country if they have a rule i
think that rule should be obeyed yeah
you can't come here and you don't have
the white man's burden now we're gonna
come and save you and liberate you
please read a book called beauty sick
and see what the western woman and this
includes the muslim woman as well what
they are going through where they're
starving themselves to a certain level
where they're not happy with their
bodies so much so that in the book that
i'm reading that a woman can express
you know in a sad state that she felt so
ugly because the beauty industry and the
standards that's given which is actually
the author says it's rigged you can
never reach those beauty standards that
she said i feel so ugly that i would
sleep around with men because that's how
worthless i felt this is how we this is
what's really going on in the background
where girls are starving themselves and
feel ugly and then you have someone like
kim kardashian who's been looked at like
a savior yes what she may have done is
good but the point is the following that
allah says you might hate something
which is good for you and love something
which is bad for you so what i'm saying
is that if we was to live in a country
i'm questioning here the muslim youth in
general men and women yani if i was to
come and say to you how many of you guys
would like to live under the sharia yeah
and once again i want to make it clear
i'm not talking about taliban to our
side that's another extreme girls can
play sports yes they might have some uh
rules on for example cameras recording
them and you need to dress up in bikinis
and all this kind of nonsense um sadly
um that we have been told but nothing
can stop a woman a group of women to
play sports the issue is not here the
sports yeah the way they're making it
out to be and the western woman like kim
kardashian who sleeps around us come to
the rescue the point i'm seeing is in a
sharia government for example that is
run properly not let's say taliban yeah
it's done you might hate certain things
that it's there but it might be good for
you so running to the western world or
somewhere else you know for a better
life etc you have no idea what goes on
in the western world i live here this is
my country i live here it's not that i'm
against it but if there is problems i
would want the best for the country that
i live in so the point i'm trying to
make in a nutshell brothers and sisters
is that we should stop looking for
instant gratification of oh we're in the
west everyone's if it's going to be
amazing oh i can take off my hijab etc
and i can go and do please please go and
look at some stats because when you
really find out what on earth goes on
and how miserable people are and mental
health is a pandemic you would then
realize to yourself that
what we thought was good is actually not
good for us and i'm not saying the
western world has a lot of things to
offer we can practice our religion and
peace i'm not talking about those
elements i'm talking about
seeing and looking up to individuals who
have zero to offer they actually minus
and that is the point i wanted to do
this video that it's sad that we've seen
a group of muslim women afghani women
rejoicing and happy seeing kim
kardashian and it to me is so
disappointing because as muslim woman
islam has come to honor you you know and
like us again i'm not talking about the
taliban here yeah islam has come to on
you and give you your rights to such a
level yeah and for you to go and look at
up to an individual and get
gas and they have nothing to offer but
filth
till next time brothers and sisters may
also finally protect us and make us look
forward to real role models like
and many other female role models in
society rather than looking at these
individuals who absolutely have nothing
to offer may allah keep us firm till
next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi